ANDREW WALES: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to "Behind the Code." In
this week's episode, we're
going to be talking all
about Google Tag
Manager for Mobile Apps.
My name's Andrew Wales.
I'm on the analytics developer
relations team.
And with me in the studio
today is Neil Rhodes.
He's the tech lead on Google Tag
Manager for Mobile Apps.
Neil, thanks for joining us.
NEIL RHODES: Well, thanks
for having me.
I look forward to doing this.
ANDREW WALES: Great.
So Google Tag Manager for Mobile
Apps launched publicly
a couple weeks ago.
NEIL RHODES: It was
August, yes.
ANDREW WALES: August.
And beyond doing all of the very
nice flexible tagging of
analytics tools and conversion
tools, as you might know that
GTM does on the web, there's
actually a lot in GTM, Tag
Manager for Mobile Apps, that's
really designed to make
life a lot simpler for app
developers as well.
So I'm excited to have you here
and go through everything
that's available for all of
you app developers to take
advantage of.
So let's take a quick look
at what's on tap.
Neil's going to give you a quick
overview of what Tag
Manager for Mobile is designed
to do and what problems it's
designed to help you solve.
We'll talk a little bit about
how you can work with the SDK,
how you do some of the core
things you need to do with it.
And we'll show you some code
snippets there as well, just
to make things more clear.
We'll talk about containers,
macros, rules and tags.
And these are the four building
blocks in GTM.
These are the things you're
going to be working with in
the web interface.
And just so you know where to
go, we'll also walk you
through the web interface, how
to use that to do some of the
very basic tasks when you're
working with GTM in your
containers.
And then lastly I'll show you
guys some resources that you
can use after the GDL to go
check out more information and
get started with GTM as well.
Cool.
So let's get started We'll start
at a very high level,
just to give everyone who's not
already familiar with GTM
for Mobile Apps an idea of
what this is all about.
So Neil, can you give us an
overview of what are the
problems that Tag Manager
for Mobile Apps
was designed to solve?
NEIL RHODES: Sure.
So a big problem with mobile
apps is unlike, let's say, a
web application, a mobile
application is really frozen.
So you ship the application.
Until you ship a new version, it
maintains its behavior and
appearance.
And that's part of what GTM
for Mobile Apps addresses.
So the idea is normally
what happens is
you ship a new version.
In order to ship a new version,
you've got to secure
approvals, either from your
own people or also from
application stores.
You've then got an upgrade
cycle, where people may or may
not be upgrading.
And so out in the field,
you've got a lot
of different versions.
We're not quite sure what
versions you have.
What happens with GTM is we
actually go ahead and have a
single representation of
configuration information
that's stored up in the web,
and that gets downloaded to
each container.
So once you want to make
a change, that will get
downloaded to your
application.
And then your application has
access to these new values
pretty much immediately.
So what are the sorts
of things you
might want to configure?
Well, the first thing is you've
got to actually write
your application so that it
is highly configurable.
So if you've got things like how
often you want to show an
ad, where you want to show an
ad, a host you need to talk to
on a back end or a timeout in
talking to that host, if you
have a game, how many points do
you get when you kill a bad
guy, any URLs for help or
something else-- all of that's
configurable, and really you
just need to make sure that in
your application you have an
API call to get that value.
So you pass in a string,
you get back a value.
And the key point that GTM for
Mobile Apps provides is you're
always getting the latest and
greatest value, not what's
just locked into the
application.
As well, GTM also provides
tagging, like its name says.
So Google Tag Manager for Web
was intended to provide the
ability to do tagging-- that is,
do things like analytics
calls or AdWords conversion
calls or
third-party type calls.
And you just have to tag
your pages once.
And then you can go ahead and
make changes using GTM and
have those affected.
The same thing is sort of
true on applications.
So what you do is you add to
your application calls when
anything interesting is
happening in your application.
And then there's this level of
indirection so that later on
you can go ahead and say when
this particular interesting
thing happens, I want
to go ahead and make
an analytics call.
Or when this happens, I want to
make an AdWords conversion
tracking call.
Or when this happens, I want to
ping this particular URL,
so hit this particular URL.
So that's really the universal
analytics, the AdWords
conversion tracking, and then
these custom image tags.
As we'll see later on, there's
also the possibility of having
just a custom function
that gets executed.
So you have a call that happens
in your application
based on rules that you
specified after the fact.
ANDREW WALES: Great.
So let's talk about working
with the Tag Manager SDK.
And actually, this is part of
the analytic services SDK,
which is Tag Manager and Google
Analytics combined into
one package.
So maybe we'll walk through some
of the basic tasks that
you're going to want to do
with the SDK-- opening a
container, getting configuration
values, pushing
the data layer, and also
previewing a container.
That's be great.
NEIL RHODES: Sure.
Well, what we've tried to do is
make this really as simple
as possible.
So first, initialization--
the first thing you
do is actually
just get the Tag Manager.
So TagManager.getInstance.
And from there, then,
you need to open
a particular container.
So a container is these
collections of macros, tags,
and rules we'll talk about
a little bit later.
But it's identified by a
particular container ID of the
form GTM-dash some four, five,
or six-character sequence.
So the first thing you do
is open your container.
And you just provide
the container ID.
You can provide a timeout.
Although if you don't provide
one, a default
is going to be used.
That doesn't actually return.
So let's make clear
what happens.
When you are first running your
app for the very first
time, there's been no
communication to the web.
So you run your application, and
it needs to actually go to
the web to get the current
version of a container.
Now, we don't know how long
that's going to take, and we
also don't even know
whether we're
connected to the network.
So what we do is when you call
openSaved, we return what's
called a future--
that is, in the background it's
going to be going through
and doing its network
communication so that we don't
stall while we're waiting
to open the container.
While that's going on, you
could do additional
initialization of your
application.
And then when you're ready and
actually need a container
value, you'll call
containerfuture.get, and that
will, if necessary, wait until
the download has happened.
Once you have a container,
four basic calls--
you can getLong, getString,
getDouble, or getBoolean.
You provide a string, and it
gives you back something of
the same type.
So if you have specified, for
instance, your timeout for
talking to a backend host,
timeout in milliseconds, call
container to getLong, and
that'll return that value, the
latest and greatest value
that has been
set up on the website.
One thing just to point out
about that, actually--
when you're calling getLong
or any of these get calls,
there's no network communication
happening.
So the network communication
has already happened.
And we download the entire
container, and now we're just
doing local calls.
So these are not terribly
expensive calls.
If you run your application
and there is no network
connection--
so let's say in fact your user
has never connected to the
network, what value should
be used for this?
You don't want to force that
your application has to be
connected to the network the
first time you run, so
therefore there's a
default container.
And the default container
is a JSON file.
Or you can also create your
container on the website and
just download and use
that binary format.
And that has initial values
for all of your keys that
you've set up that you want to
be getting the values of.
So that way when you ship your
application, you're shipping
not just the application, you're
also shipping this
default container.
And that way your application
can run as is without any
network connection.
Once you make a network
connection-- so once a network
connection happens and we
download a newer version of
that container, that newer
version of the container will
be used until there's
an even newer
version of the container.
And what happens is the
application or the SDK will
check twice a day and see if
there's even a newer version.
So normally, as long as there's
a network connection,
you're no more than 12
hours out of date.
The final calls you want to
make-- so the first ones we
just saw are all you need
to do from within your
application to access these
configuration values.
The next thing you also
want to do is tagging.
And tags are executed in
response to interesting things
happening in your application.
How do you specify an
interesting thing happening?
You push to the data layer.
So the data layer is a
collection of values which you
can write to and which then the
GTM runtime can actually
have access to.
The data layer is used
for two things.
So the first thing it's used
for is just to provide
interesting runtime
information.
As an example, you might want to
provide how many times does
the user run this application,
if you might want to have some
rule based on that.
Or what's the user's lifetime
value, again, so that later on
you can have rules that
deal with that.
And then the second thing you
use the data layer for is
pushing events.
So an event is a map of values,
one of which has the
name event.
That's really what makes it
different from any other data
layer push.
And then once an event is
pushed, any associated tags
that have been registered for
that event will get executed.
As an example, then, you might
want to push an event here
when you open a screen.
So every time you go to a new
screen or new activity, when
you open a dialogue, something
like that, push an event that
says this is happening.
You can add additional data,
as we have here--
like, which screen name is it?
And that'll be useful then when
you get to the actual tag
so that you can specify
that screen name.
This is also a cheap call, so
pushing to the data layer is
quite inexpensive.
If there are no tags that have
rules associated with that
event, it's a very simple
and easy call.
So you can afford to push data
layer events really any time
anything interesting is
happening in your application.
Everything else really happens
on the web side as you're
editing your container
and creating
rules, tags, and macros.
Now, one thing that happens--
let's say you make a change on
the website to update your
container values.
How do you know they're right?
You don't really want to go
publish that container live to
the world without testing it.
And so the way to test
it is by previewing.
The way preview happens
is on the website.
You say, I want to preview the
container, and it'll give you
the new URL.
And you go to that URL on a
device, and you can see, how
would this application act if
this particular version of the
container were to be the
published version?
So that's useful for you
to do debugging.
It's useful if you hand off
to someone, like a product
manager who wants to say, what's
this going to look like
if I turn on these values,
and you can show them.
And finally, it's also useful
for application stores if
you're going through
a review process.
You may want to show them,
look, here's my initial
version of the application.
And I have these other UI
alternatives that I may be
turning on.
And let me give you a URL to
show you what those different
UI alternatives look like.
So that way you don't have any
hidden features that you're
trying to somehow sneak
by an app store.
In order to preview a container,
you do need a
little additional code.
So in your main XML file, you
will need to add an activity
that basically specifies, when
a certain URL occurs, go
execute this preview activity.
There's something similar that
happens on iOS as well.
Once you're in the website,
you've chosen the version of
the container, made your
changes, and then say you want
to preview it, it will go ahead
and generate a URL along
with a QR code.
And then you can just go to your
device and scan that QR
code or enter that URL.
And then, as I say,
your application--
from then on until your
application exits--
will be using that version of
the container rather than the
published version of
the container.
ANDREW WALES: Let's talk a bit
about containers, tags, rules,
and macros.
And Neil, you've mentioned each
of these a couple times
now in talking about how you
might want to configure your
application to receive updated
configuration values or to
fire tags, for example, when
you're pushing events to the
data layer.
So let's walk through
each of these four.
Maybe you can give us some
more details about what
exactly containers, tags,
rules, and macros are.
NEIL RHODES: I'm happy to.
So a container is a collection
of these values.
The idea is you would normally
have one container for a
website or one container
for an application.
So if you publish three
different applications, you'd
probably want to have
a container
separate for each one.
It's possible to have multiple
containers for an application,
but that's not a very
common occurrence.
So a container has a container
ID associated with it.
And as you remember, when we
initialized our container, we
provided that ID and
then got back that
container on the device.
For mobile, again, these
containers are
updated twice a day.
So when your application first
starts, it looks, sees what
version of the container it
has and how old it is, and
then goes and talks to a
back-end server to see whether
there's a new version.
If there is a new version,
it downloads it.
If not, it waits.
12 hours later, it'll try
and do that again.
Tags, as I mentioned, are
evaluated when you push an
event to the data layer.
That's the only time tags ever
fire, is when events are
pushed to the data layer.
And they're only pushed to the
data layer when you've got a
rule that associates a
particular tag with a
particular event.
Examples of tags include Google
Analytics tracking.
What does this mean?
Well, this means you can
actually take your mobile
application and get rid
of all the explicit
Google Analytics calls.
Instead you want to
have pushes of
events to the data layer.
And then in the UI you're going
to set up, when this
event happens, I want this
GA call to happen.
That's a tag.
As well, there are AdWords,
conversion remarketing tags in
the same way.
So this removes the requirement
for having to have
explicit GA calls and then a new
SDK and explicit AdWords
in conversion tracking calls.
Instead, you have a unified
model where all you're doing
is pushing events to
the data layer.
And then you have a separate
place in the UI where you're
associating as you want
those events for
the particular tags--
be it GA, be it AdWords.
Other possibility, maybe you
have some back end that you're
using, and you want particular
URLs to be hit when certain
things happen in your
application.
That's the idea of
a custom image.
So you're actually, in the
UI, building up a URL.
And that URL is going
to be retrieved.
You'll do an HTTP get
on that URL--
again, when an event occurs
that matches the
rule for that tag.
Finally, you can just have
arbitrary code executed.
So you can actually in your
application register with the
Tag Manager to say when you're
writing a particular function
associated with a particular
function name.
And so that can cause, then,
this indirection where you
push an event to the data
layer, you have a rule
associated with a particular
function tag that calls back
into your application,
and then you can
do something custom.
Unlike on the web, tags in
applications can't be executed
synchronously.
That is, we can't actually do
the HTTP get necessarily
immediately.
And the reason for that is
your application may be
running without any network
connectivity.
So in all three of these first
cases, where we're dealing
with URLs, the URL doesn't
actually get retrieved until
we actually have
network access.
So what happens is these URLs
get queued, and then we go
ahead and about 15 minutes
later go ahead
and retrieve those.
Part of the advantage of that
is better battery usage,
because we're clumping together
multiple tags and
retrieving those all at once,
rather than doing that, let's
say, once every five minutes.
Macros are name value pairs, and
the values are determined
at runtime.
It's easy to see with some
pre-defined macros.
So one macro, for instance, is
the language the user has set.
Another is the version of
the operating system.
Another is the platform.
That is, are we on iOS
or are we on Android?
So these are values that can
be retrieved at runtime and
for which you can write
rules against.
So you can write rules against
them, and you can also use any
of these macro within a tag.
Another important pre-defined
macro is a data layer macro.
So this says, actually, I want
to retrieve a value from the
data layer.
So that provides a way to write
a rule that retrieves
data from your application.
So as long as your application
has put it in the data layer,
you can have a macro, then,
that retrieves it from the
data layer.
Value collection macros are
special in that they are the
way that we have these
configuration values that are
accessible at runtime.
So when you on your container
call getString or getBoolean,
what we're looking for are
macros in the value
collection.
And we define basically JSON--
so we have multiple key value
pairs on a hierarchy.
Just like we had the function
tag where you have custom code
in your application that
executes in response to
pushing a particular event,
similarly, we have function
macros, which are custom code
that executes for a particular
macro you've registered.
So you register you want to
handle some particular kind,
and then when that kind happens,
it'll call back into
your application and it'll
ask for a value.
And then finally what
really puts it all
together are the rules.
So you specify rules for
when value collections
are going to be active.
So an example--
well, we'll see an example,
when we look at our UI
overview where you might have
one value if you're on a
particular version of the
operating system and another
value in a different version.
What rules get to do is tests
macro values, so you can do
both numerical comparisons as
well as string comparisons,
like regexes and so on.
For a given tag, you
can specify--
it will execute if any of these
rules are true and as
long as none of these other
rules are true.
So you can have both enabling
and disabling or allowing and
blocking rules.
ANDREW WALES: Yeah, one
follow-up question, Neil,
about function tags.
So it gives you the
ability to--
based on some event that's
pushed into the data layer, so
something interesting happens
in the app, it lets you then
create a rule that says, when
this event occurs, I want to
call this particular function.
NEIL RHODES: That's right.
ANDREW WALES: But when you do
that, you're actually calling
back into the app.
You're not actually providing
code via the web interface
that's going to run it.
NEIL RHODES: That's
a good point.
So yeah, when you have a
function tag, what's happening
is the code has to be in your
application already.
So you have to have prepared
your application to have this
custom function.
an example where you might
want to have this custom
function would be, let's say
you have a third-party SDK
that does some other form of
tracking that GTM doesn't
currently support.
So you could go ahead and have
a custom function that calls
into that third-party SDK, and
then you can write rules, just
as you normally would for GA.
ANDREW WALES: Right.
So that would be way
to extend it.
So if you're not using GA or if
you want to use something
else, you could use these
function tags to enforce that.
NEIL RHODES: Exactly.
ANDREW WALES: Cool.
So let's actually take a look
at the web interface where
you're going to be creating
all of these containers,
macros, tags, and rules.
So Neil, I think you can give us
a little run through on the
UI if we can switch
to your screen.
NEIL RHODES: Sure,
I'd be happy to.
So google.com/tagmanager
is where we're at.
And I'm going to go ahead--
I've already created
an account.
I'm going to create
a container.
So containers all have names.
This is just for your use.
I'm going to call it GDL Demo.
And as you can see, there are
two different kinds of
containers--
those for web pages and
those for mobile apps.
We, of course, are interested
in mobile apps here.
And we're going to go ahead
and have this container
support both Android and iOS.
Now, you can share a container
between your iOS and your
Android app, and you'd want to
do so if they are fairly
similar to each other.
If they're using completely
different sorts of tagging and
different sorts of configuration
values, then you
really want to have two
separate containers.
In this case, we're
going to use one.
And you can see we can
now download the SDK.
As Andrew mentioned, it's a
combined Google Analytics and
Google Tag Manager SDK.
I don't need to do that right
now because we're just
looking at the UI.
And we can now configure
the container.
So in fact, let's just
look at what the
container has already.
It has a rule--
always, which is basically a
rule that's always true--
and then a bunch of macros for
all of the built-in things,
like finding out the application
ID, the name of
the version, finding out what
device name we are on, the
language, ID for advertising,
and resolutions and so on.
What I'd like to do is
create a new macro.
I want to do some configuration
in my
application to be able
to get a string.
So this is going to be my
configuration values.
And I'm going to create
a value collection.
In this value collection,
we're going to have--
so what are we going
to be customizing?
Well, actually, let's
not get a string.
Let's get a Boolean.
So I've got a new UI
element that I want
to be able to display.
So enableMyNewUIFeature.
Feature And we're going to set
that to be false, because we
don't want people to actually
see this new UI feature yet.
And then we also have a back-end
timeout value for a
back-end server we talk to
of 2,000 milliseconds.
So this specifies a value
collection, however we need to
also specify rules for it.
If we don't specify any rules,
it won't have any effect.
I'm going to go ahead and create
an enabling rule which
says it's always true
and say this.
So as I look at my overview,
I can see I now have my
configuration values, and I can
see what I have set up.
What's the next thing to do?
Create a version.
And I can go ahead
and publish it.
So that means that my
application out there will now
be using this value.
Let's create a modification
list.
Let's actually make it so it's
targeted as to when this
feature is on or off.
So I'm going to create
a macro.
Let's call this enableUIFeature.
Let's disable it on iOS, and
we'll enable it on Android.
So I'm going to go ahead
and set this--
let's see, I want
iOS to be false.
And when is this going
to be true?
This is going to
be true on iOS.
I don't have a rule for iOS,
but I can create one.
And what I can do is look
at the platform.
So if the platform is equal to
iOS, then that rule is true.
And if this rule is true, this
macro is going to be true.
Therefore, it's going to
be used, I should say.
And I want to create also a
version of this for Android.
So enabled on Android.
So enable the UI feature.
And this was-- now, I have to
make sure to get this right--
enableUIFeature.
When do we want this
to be true?
Well, we want this to be
true only in Android.
We could write a separate on
Android rule, or we can take
advantage of the disabling
rules.
So we can say it's always going
to be true, except we're
disabling it when it's on iOS.
So we now have enable the UI
feature on iOS, and enable the
UI feature on Android.
And you can see here, I've
spelled one of them wrong.
One is enable my new UI feature,
and one is just
enable UI feature.
So I better go edit that to make
sure they're the same.
And the last change we want to
make is we actually have some
overlap right now.
So enable my new UI feature, if
we're on iOS, is going to
be false due to this macro, but
it's actually going to be
true due to my configuration
values.
And we really don't want
to multiply specify.
So we just want to remove
it from here.
So what do we have set up?
Now back-end timeout is going to
be 2,000 on all platforms,
enable my new UI feature is
going to be false on iOS, and
it's going to be true on
anything but iOS--
in this case, that's
just Android.
OK, so let's go ahead and look
at creating a tag to call
Google Analytics when a new
screen occurs-- that is, when
we have an event for
tracking a screen.
So this is going to be, let's
say, our GA screen view.
And we're going to use
Universal Analytics.
We need to provide a course for
Google Analytics to the
tracking ID.
I'm of course not putting in
a real tracking ID here.
And what do we want to do?
We want the tracking type--
so again, this is just for
universal analytics.
What are the different types of
things that you can track?
In our case, we're going
to track an app view.
And what do we want to track?
Well, we want to provide
the app name.
Rather than typing in the app
name here, it's a little more
flexible to go ahead and use the
pre-existing macro for the
app name that's going to get
it from the actual APK.
Similarly for that version.
Now, the screen name, where
do we get that?
That's not a fixed value.
If you remember, when we pushed
to the data layer, we
pushed a map containing an
event, map to open screen, and
screen name mapped to whatever
the name of the screen was.
So we actually want from
the data layer
a screen name value.
That's not pre-defined.
We're going to have
to create it.
So we can have a data
layer value here.
And this is going to
be a screen name.
And this name here, the delayed
variable name, that's
exactly the name that we used
when we pushed the event.
So we've set up what the tag's
going to look like.
We're going to be doing an app
view tag, and it's going to
have the app name, app version,
and screen name, and
that's all we really need.
However, now we need a rule
when we fire this.
Do we want it always?
No, that would say on every
single event that gets pushed
to the data layer,
this would fire.
And that's not really
appropriate.
We don't want an iOS.
We need a new rule.
So this is going to be on
an open screen event.
So how do we tell when it's
an open screen event?
Well, that is if the event
is equal to open screen.
And again, open screen was the
name that we used when we
actually pushed the
data layer event.
So your application is going to
call the data layer push.
It'll be pushing an event called
open screen with a
screen name called
home screen.
This rule is going to make
sure that this tag guess
fired, and the screen data layer
macro is going to pull
that screen name from
that push value.
So from here we can create
a version, and
we can publish it.
But as I mentioned, let's say
we want to test it first.
So we can go ahead
and use preview.
And here we knew the name
of the application.
This name has to match what is
in your XML file that was
associated with setting up
the preview activity.
So I'm going to just call it my
app for right now, and it
generates a preview link.
So basically what we need
to do in the device
is go to this link--
or alternatively scan
this QR code--
and that will then start using
this version of the container
we just created that has the
extra tag and also has a
differential UI future
based on whether
on iOS or on Android.
Once we're happy with it, then
we can go ahead and publish.
The last thing I want to show
you is Download here.
So Download is actually going
to download this version of
the container.
And this can then be used as
your default container.
So not only can you have a
default container that just
contains values, you can also
have a default container that
needs values, tags,
rules, macros--
the whole shebang.
ANDREW WALES: And I think that's
an important point.
Because if you have rules set
up, for example, or tags, and
you want to have a default
container that has all those
things, then you should use
the binary version.
Obviously the JSON version
is not going to be
sufficient in that case.
NEIL RHODES: Yeah, the JSON
version might be OK if you
just have configuration
type values.
But if you're doing tagging,
then you probably really do
want to go ahead and have an
initial set of tags that are
pre-configured in your
application.
And then you can always go ahead
and override those by
going to the UI.
ANDREW WALES: Great.
So that brings us towards
the end of the program.
I did want to pass off some
resources to you guys.
But before we did to that, I
just want to quickly recap
what we talked about, because
Neil just ran through a whole
bunch of information.
And I want to make sure that
it's not lost on anybody how
powerful this stuff can be.
So we talked a little bit
about being able to push
configuration values to your
app via this web interface.
And Neil, this basically means
that you can actually update
your app in the wild, in
the hands of users.
And it's under 12
hours, right?
NEIL RHODES: That's right.
ANDREW WALES: And that's much
quicker than having to rebuild
the app, resubmit it for review,
and then follow that
long tail out of adoption as
people decide to update the
app or not.
On that point, is there any--
some people might be
wondering, does
this cause any issues--
when you submit your app to be
approved or reviewed and
approved by Google or Apple or
somebody else, does this is
cause any issues to
have this kind of
logic with Tag Manager?
You mentioned the preview URLs
were one way to solve that.
NEIL RHODES: That's really
the way to deal with.
We do not recommend that you
have inside your application
different features or different
UI that's sort of
hidden behind a flag
that you don't tell
Google or Apple about.
And the way to expose that and
allow them to look at it is
really with those
preview links.
So you could actually have
multiple preview
links if you want.
You have five different
features, let's say, and you
might go ahead and have five
different preview links and
just say, here's these things
that could be exposed in the
future or even tell them when
they would be exposed.
ANDREW WALES: And then when
you're ready to make them go
live, it's just enabling it in
the interface and that's
pretty much it.
That's very cool.
The other thing we talked
about, not just getting
configuration values from the
web, but also tagging.
So you can create these tags
that will basically--
when interesting things happen
in the app, you can have this
layer of indirection--
which you called it, Neil--
where you push the events into
the data layer, and then you
decide what you want to do
when those events get fired.
So maybe you want to fire some
analytics tags, or maybe you
want to track an AdWords
conversion, and so forth.
Maybe one question--
I know some people might
be wondering--
and you talked about it a little
bit, but obviously
there's going to be some people
who are uneasy about
the idea of it might slow down
the application, for example,
to be pushing things into
the data layer.
Or even just refreshing the
container in general--
I might be concerned with the
app starts up, how long is
that going to take?
Is it going to block?
What if I have UI values that I
need right away, and I don't
want to see the screen shifting
in front of anybody
as the values change or
anything like that?
Can you just speak generally to
anybody's performance concerns?
NEIL RHODES: Sure.
So there are a couple aspect.
So let's start with the
easier ones first.
So getting a value, when you
make a get call, getString or
so on, those are really
very fast.
All they're doing is evaluating
a subset of small
rules and then figuring out what
to do and returning that.
Pushing to the data layer is
also relatively quick, in that
first it's just looking
and seeing--
well, first off, if there's no
event, nothing gets executed.
Well, no specific extra
code gets executed.
It writes to a data layer, which
is very simple in memory
data structure.
If it's an event, we look and
see, are there any tags
associated with that for which
we have to try to figure out
the rules and so on.
And if so, same simple
rule evaluation.
And then tag execution
is fairly quick.
So it's not, for instance,
like our tags are
synchronously waiting
and trying to
send over the network.
Really, we just quickly store
it and then later on in a
separate thread, that's
going to be sent.
ANDREW WALES: How long do
those stay queued up?
So if the device doesn't
have connection, a
couple tags are fired.
We queue up those requests.
And then if somewhere were to,
for example, close the app and
restart it, would it then make
those requests, or are they
gone after the app is closed?
NEIL RHODES: So couple
different answers--
the short answer is no,
they do stay there.
So we save them in a
persistent storage.
And when the application
reopens, then we would try to
resend them again.
It's not even so bad as that on
Android, because on Android
your application, even when
you leave the application,
it's normally still running
in the background.
And so it should
still be sent.
It's only if your application
actually forcibly quit, if
you're sort of memory or
something like that, that we
would then have to wait until
the next time the
application was run.
As far as the container opening,
you really have to
decide how important it is, for
one thing, that you get
the current version of the
container before you
display your UI.
One possibility-- and we have an
example of this-- is have a
splash screen.
So have a quick splash screen
that then can-- you can do all
of your initialization
including container
initialization.
And once the container
is there, you
can continue forward.
In some extreme examples, you
might say if I can't get a
container from the network
I don't want to run.
That would be an extreme case.
If you're just using your
container for things like host
names or values or things like
that, you probably want to go
ahead and issue the request to
get the container and then
continue on your way.
And when it comes in, you'll
get those values.
And if not, you'll revert
to the default.
If you've got a UI issue, where
for instance you have a
complete new UI based on the
version of the container,
that's the case where you
probably want to wait.
Because it would look kind of
funny to use the default
version, which might have UI
version A, and then when the
container actually downloads and
says to use version B, you
suddenly start switching to
version B. So I think that's
the flashing you talked about.
ANDREW WALES: But that's kind
of important to notice that
you could actually ship a whole
new UI by pushing all
these updated configuration
values.
It kind of speaks to the power
of the product that you could
actually do that.
NEIL RHODES: Well, yes and no.
You're the one that was having
to do it in your application.
So if you have two different
versions of your UI, maybe all
it is is you just have a Boolean
that you're sending
down, and you have a
lot of code there.
On the other hand, you could
also make it fairly
configurable and send down all
sorts of information, like
what belongs on a particular
screen or how it's laid out.
It could be quite
configurable.
So the Google Analytics app,
in fact, takes advantage of
that, the mobile application.
They go ahead and have a very
configurable information they
said down via GTM, and they can
add new reports, remove
reports, modify reports,
all using GTM.
And it'll just affect all of the
applications in the wild.
ANDREW WALES: And in about
12 hours or so.
Very cool.
Awesome.
Well, I think that brings us
to the end of the time.
Just a few resources--
obviously, if you want to just
get started with the product,
you can just go right to it.
It's google.com/tagmanager.
We also have getting started
guides for Android and iOS.
A lot of the examples we gave
today and a lot of the code we
showed was specific to Android,
but there are
equivalents for everything
that we
showed for iOS as well.
So you can find those guides
on the developer site.
Other than that, thank
you for joining us.
We're talking this week about
Google Tag Manager for Mobile.
And we'll catch you next time.